[Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  always the wall  [Music]  wanna break  [Music]  Oh  dirty wall tonight won't fess up  all to do a custom okay roll this side  Judy rose  [Music]  it's still alive nice Lobos victory  there tied up  we'll be supposed to get opportunity  below  this has a tremendous potential to kill  this  well  Oh  [Music]  fighters right now  so 32 seconds  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  no blue tonight Oh  [Music]  [Music]  Oh  do it  Oh  yeah  ya know he stepped over this jay-z shut  up saying we got bad boy on Kentucky and  he has rigs on the shoulder hit anything  Oh Lord again  now one  Hey  picks up what you do Steve oh sorry way  beyond get dr. Reagan doing  all right there  [Music]  Jonah's